este alimentador 100 eléctrico hace
parte de la red de buses de lyon pero en
su interior no hay un conductor el
vehículo es autónomo pues usted ve lo
que el alimentador ve el vehículo que
adelanta el alimentador fue construido
por la sociedad francesa navia una
empresa especializada en la concepción
de vehículos sin conductores del
alimentador cuenta con captores le
permiten detectar objetos su entorno
como este entorno se desplaza como
interfiere con el alimentador y él
decide en tiempo real cómo ajustar su
comportamiento un comportamiento
dirigido por este panel de instrumentos
pero gracias al 5g
no había espera a relocalizar la
supervisión en una oficina y sobre todo
mejorar los tiempos de respuesta del
vehículo por la problemática será una
problemática de tiempo entre el envío de
la imagen al puesto de control hoy en
día con el 4g somos capaces de enviar
imágenes a un puesto de control en la
medida en que la imagen llega a tres
segundos después aunque la persona en el
puesto de control dice el vehículo puede
volver a atacar muchas cosas han podido
pasar
la quinta generación de telefonía móvil
se anuncia como una revolución para el
transporte inteligente y los vehículos
conectados una tecnología esperada
también con impaciencia por el sector
salud para desarrollar la telemedicina
los industriales ya se imaginan fábricas
conectadas y digitalizadas al 100% y
según algunos estudios el 5g podría
compensar pérdidas de empleos con la
creación de 2 millones de puestos más
calificados pero el despliegue necesario
de antenas para su funcionamiento
suscita dudas e incluso una férrea
oposición de ajemex y es el referente en
parís de la asociación joven de los
techos que milita contra estas antenas
nos reunimos con él en un barrio de la
localidad a 20
esta antena irradiar a una buena parte
del barrio pero en especial a una
guardería y radio una guardería y a una
escuela primaria
vinícola
las consecuencias de las ondas
electromagnéticas en el hombre son uno
de los principales argumentos de los
anti 5g el instituto nacional de salud y
de la investigación médica inserm
considera que las ondas de las antenas
de 5g siguen siendo muy débiles como
para ser nocivas pero joven considera
que esos estudios no analizan las
consecuencias a largo plazo
la anses agencia de seguridad sanitaria
está haciendo un estudio que entregará
en enero de 2021 es decir más allá de la
puesta en marcha del 5g
esto ha enfurecido a varios funcionarios
de izquierda principalmente a los
alcaldes de algunas de las ciudades más
grandes de francia 70 de esos
funcionarios publicaron una carta
abierta en septiembre pidiendo al
gobierno que presione el botón de pausa
en el lanzamiento de 5 g hasta que se
publique ese informe respuesta del
gobierno los estudios existentes son
suficientes para un despliegue desde el
final de año
lo que sabemos con base en 28 mil
estudios con base en un despliegue en 22
países entre los cuales países que velan
por la salud de sus ciudadanos los
países escandinavos japón que podemos
tomar como ejemplo es que no hay impacto
en la salud de kenia para camps action
es anti
sin embargo para algunas asociaciones el
despliegue del 5g no tiene nada de
inevitable actuar por el medio ambiente
radicó un recurso ante el consejo de
estado para anular la atribución de las
frecuencias podríamos solicitar la
prohibición del 5g 3 o les estamos
pidiendo un debate público y un estudio
de impacto para obtener informaciones
sobre el impacto sanitario y energético
ya que la llegada del 5g hace que
millones de teléfonos inteligentes 4g se
vuelvan obsoletos otra preocupación
medioambiental la energía que
necesitarán miles de millones de objetos
conectados al mismo tiempo el volumen de
datos intercambiados será inédito un
volumen que también genera preocupación
que ocurrirá con la vida privada tales
grupo francés de electrónica
comercializa sus soluciones de seguridad
digital en 180 países entre los cuales
algunos ya han puesto en marcha el 5g
no se trata de estimar en cifras todos
los datos sería demasiado pero estimar
las que son esenciales ya sea con los
proveedores de cloud a quienes se le
instala y probé estas soluciones ya sea
a proveedores de aplicaciones que
trabajan con nosotros y cuando tengan un
proveedor de cloud dicen en cuanto a la
clave no quiero trabajar con la clave de
google o amazon quiero trabajar con la
clave de tales temores por la vida
privada inquietudes de sanitarias y
medioambientales
la llegada del 5g constituye a tierra
fértil para las teorías complotistas y
las acciones más radicales durante los
últimos meses en francia más de 50
antenas fueron vandalizadas en todo el
territorio